recently i've been getting the
impression that there might be this
slight misconception online that i am
somehow highly organized and have my
life together and i just want to say
that this cannot be farther from the
truth when i am being generous with
myself i call myself an artistic spirit
and when i'm being realistic i call
myself a chaotic mess which is what my
life looks like most of the time one
thing that i struggle with a lot is
habit formation i don't like habits i
don't like sticking to them i don't like
creating them i don't like having them
it's just very very hard for me to keep
doing things regularly and so of course
i had to go to the scientific literature
to understand what really creates habits
and what are the good and bad things how
can i be somehow sabotaging potentially
myself in my habit creation and
improving my life and because it is the
season in january to kind of get
ourselves together and start to
establish new routines and schedules i
thought what better time to kind of
share what i found with you so in this
video i'm going to go through firstly
two things that we might be doing
already which i think are kind of like
general advice which is very common
around habit formation which actually
might be sabotaging the formation of
your habits so
general advice that is not good and then
on the flip side also some other things
that we could be doing instead in order
to create better habits so let's get
started the first thing that we might
instinctively think is good but is
actually bad for our habits is creating
very strict schedules around when to do
things so writing to-do lists such as
i'm going to wake up at 8am and then i'm
going to go to the gym until 9 and then
i'm going to do 400 past med questions
and then i'm going to write 3 000 words
of my essay and run a half marathon
these sort of scheduling of habits tend
to not work in the long term and this
has definitely been the case for me i've
very ambitiously created these very
strict routines for my life and i can
tell you right now they never last a
long time they are never able to
healthily stick to these for weeks let
alone months or years potentially and if
you're the kind of person who says well
this actually works very well for me are
these habits that you enjoy doing for
very very long times or are these things
that you forced yourself to do
temporarily because this tends to be the
difference between long-term habits and
short-term habits so it might be that
just scheduling things in very in a very
strict to-do list kind of way is
actually counterproductive towards
establishing habits that you find
enjoyable the second thing which i quite
enjoy to hear is that putting
notifications on your phone for example
or electronic devices is a bad way to
establish habits we tend to in the long
term just ignore these notifications and
we don't internalize the process of
doing something again and again so they
tend to be a bad way to establish a
long-term habit they might work
temporarily to remind you to do
something but they will do very little
for internalizing a behavior
consistently for the future okay great
so these are two things that we can
ignore doing what should we be doing
instead the first thing is quite
interesting and fun and that is putting
yourself through a mental exercise of
doing an activity consistently before or
instead of actually doing it so for
example let's say i want to establish a
habit of going to the gym because i'm
just not doing this what would be a good
thing for me to do is to just close my
eyes and imagine every single step in as
much detail as possible that would take
me from what i'm doing right now to
being in the gym so for example i will
get off this couch right now and i'm
going to go to my closet and i'm going
to get my gym clothes and put my gym
gear on i'm going to take my bag and my
face mask and very importantly my
airpods and my phone and my keys i'm
going to walk out my door go to my
elevator so every single detailed step
hooking ourselves through this will
reinforce the neural pathways in our
brain which are responsible for us
actually doing these activities so
through role-playing these activities
very safely in our minds we are actually
reducing the activation energy that is
necessary for physically doing these
activities in the future so something
which is very easy to do is that in your
free time if for example you have
decided that you're going to
procrastinate tonight and you're just
not going to write that essay you're
just not going to go to the gym what you
can do instead which would still be a
productive thing is just to close your
eyes and imagine you actually doing that
activity because it will make it much
more likely apparently that you can do
it with a lot less friction eventually
in the future and establish this habit
in a stronger way second thing has to do
with timing around habits and it kind of
ties into what i mentioned earlier in
that very strictly planning and
scheduling when you're going to do
things is a bad way to establish a
long-term habit the dorsolateral
striatum is what becomes activated
before and after we do a task so when we
are performing a task or establishing a
habit we are kind of bracketing this
around the activation of the
dorsolateral striatum so we are
bracketing around what we do before and
what we do after and so the more
established the habit the weaker this
connection so any sort of activity that
we want to do we want to make it as
loosely associated as possible with
everything around it because imagine if
we had these very strict schedules of
i'm only going to do b if a happens and
then i'm only going to do c if b happens
it's very unlikely that these things
won't become completely chaotic at some
point if i only go to the gym after i've
had my very special breakfast smoothie
what happens on the days that i don't
have the ingredients for my smoothie and
if i'm only going to do my past med
exercises on the days that i have had a
good workout what happens when i don't
do a good workout and just making these
things so dependent on one another and
what happens before and after them means
that we're much less likely to create a
habit and our strongest habits are those
that are as most context independent as
possible which basically means are those
activities that we can do no matter what
else is happening around us for example
brushing your teeth tends to be a very
context independent activity because for
most of us no matter how tired we are no
matter what time of the day we are going
to sleep no matter when we are supposed
to wake up the next morning no matter
what kind of mood we are in no matter if
we've had or haven't had dinner for most
of us we will brush our teeth no matter
what this is a very context independent
activity while tying things into a to-do
list or into a strict schedule means
that we will be very context-dependent
in the habits that we are creating and
therefore those habits tend to be weaker
having said this very interestingly
there is another way to kind of plan
when you are supposed to do things that
is not dependent on what you have done
in the day but is dependent on the
phasing or time of the day i found this
way of viewing habits very very
interesting when you divide your day
into three phases phase one is the first
eight hours after you wake up
irrespective when you wake up you might
be at 8am person or you might be a 4am
person it doesn't matter the second
phase is the 8 to 16 hours after you
wake up and the third phase is the 16 to
24 hours after you wake up the first
eight hours are those wherein you have
the most energy to do things that you
don't want to do so this is where you
put the activities that you really don't
enjoy and the new habits that you are
creating that take a lot of physical or
mental energy or physical or mental
barriers to get over if you despise
going to the gym this might be the time
to do it if you despise studying or
doing questions or doing a project or
doing work this is the time to do it in
the second phase of the day this is
where you do the activities that do take
mental and physical energy but you find
a bit more enjoyable this is why i
realize i am a evening gym person i'm
not a morning gym person and i find it
very easy and enjoyable to go to the gym
in the evening because even though it
takes a lot of physical energy it
doesn't take a lot of mental energy for
me because i actually want to do it but
if you would hate the gym it would be
good to do that in the morning on the
opposite side doing things such as like
studying sometimes that's not my
favorite thing to do so it's not good
for me to leave that as the last thing
in the day but it's better for me to do
that in phase one of the day and in
phase three where we should be sleeping
this is where we put the habits which
take very little physical or emotional
energy so these are things like oh i
want to start a journaling habit or i
want to read a bit more or i want to
call my parents this is a good time to
establish these habits because
these are things that we very much want
to do but are not too tiring unless of
course you find feeding very very
difficult in which case you might want
to upgrade it to a phase two or a phase
one of the day so kind of seeing the day
in this way where in if you want to
establish the habit you ask yourself hmm
how much activation energy does this
have is this something that i really
enjoy doing is this something that i
could do when i'm tired or do i want to
do it first thing in the morning kind of
like swallow the frog and slutting it
there and also moving it around so
sometimes doing it in hour one sometimes
doing it in hour seven sometimes doing
it in hour three or phase one will make
it very context independent and very
likely that you can repeat this activity
again and again so yes going down the
pathway of scientific exploration and
studies that i go through for these
videos kind of puts me in this mindset
of wanting to learn more about science
and understanding how things work and
one thing that i've been using over the
last few months to kind of supplement my
scientific literacy is using brilliant
which are very kindly sponsoring this
video the thing that i like about
brilliant is that i can use puzzles and
games so i can definitely do this as a
phase three activity before i go to
sleep and i end up surprisingly learning
things where i think that oh why was
this never explained this way for me in
high school or university i'm currently
working through the statistic courses
because they tend to be my least
favorite part of maths when i was in
school but unfortunately kind of the
most one of the most important parts of
maths if you are approaching scientific
literature i'm hopefully becoming a bit
more interested in this sort of
mathematical thinking if you would like
to join me on this phase the activity
there will be a link in my description
where you can try out brilliant and get
a discount on the yearly subscription
otherwise if you made it to the end of
this video thank you so much for
spending this time with me i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day be
kind yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think thanks bye